being a basketball player spacejam was
huge I had like a Space Jam themed
birthday party and like cake where we
played basketball and all my friends
watched Space Jam that night so that was
a big one for me
[Music]
well media was a company that my partner
and I started about three years ago I
started talking about four years ago I
just wanted to get into film TV digital
and have you know lay the foundation for
a company that you know we can run once
we're done with our current careers I
wasn't really focused on running a media
company it's just that movies and TV was
such a big part of my life and still is
that I just kind of stumbled into it
somehow and through doing commercials
and then getting a little bit more
creative control here and there and then
realizing that I really enjoyed the
whole process it was kind of how this
came about
[Music]
my dad was a teacher and a coach my both
my parents were high school teachers
that's how I met and then my dad just
out of necessity started a trophy
company like an awards company which you
know just helped my parents you know
have extra income on the side and and
you know both my parents for me or two
artists working people I know and that's
sort of where my brother and I both have
kind of set our work ethic and their
standards so but it is nice to be able
to now you know venture out and do
things a little bit outside of that not
just not out of necessity but also just
because you enjoy that or it's
interesting to you
[Music]
the beauty of you know media today
there's so many outlets and there's so
many platforms that you can watch you
know whatever whatever it is you like
you can find that really niche thing
that you know you might not have been
able to watch you know 10-15 years ago I
think the biggest like WoW moment is
just the amount of time it takes for
some projects to actually come to time
come to fruition I've heard stories
about you know people having an idea or
having a script or having whatever they
have and not getting made for you know
10 15 20 years so with that said you
know it's also comforting knowing that
like if something doesn't work out here
there's always a second window or second
opportunity to maybe showcase that and
figure out a way to pivot and use that
somewhere later
[Music]